this boy is a victim of what the un says
is the world's worst hunger crisis
he may not look it but adan moes is 14
years old his uncle says that after
spending months hiding from violence in
ethiopia's tagray region he weighs less
than 15 kilograms
and he's not alone the un estimates
hundreds of thousands of people are
suffering famine conditions in tegra and
millions more at risk after fighting
left many hospitals and clinics closed
or destroyed
the combination of lack of medical care
most of the health institutions there
are inoperable
and lack of food will mean that people
will start to die
fighting broke out into gry in november
between the ethiopian military and the
regional force the tegrai people's
liberation front
we're looking at almost a year of
fighting that had a
tremendous impact on the economy and
agriculture and
the ability of people to produce food so
now what we see is that many people they
only have one meal per day the quality
of their meals have also deteriorated
some people are now eating roots and
flowers to survive
the un says a de facto government
blockade of the region is preventing
food medical supplies and fuel from
getting in something the government's
denied
ethiopia is
is a stain on our conscience because the
uh the the facts show that access to
tigre where we
have been wanting to have a hundred
trucks every day arrive integrate to
meet the needs of the over 5 million
people there
we've never reached that we've never had
that and it's been about 10 percent of
that over the last two or three months
the un humanitarian chief says
ethiopia's leaders are peering into the
abyss
and he's calling on all sides to stop
the fighting before this man-made famine
gets worse
alexio bryan al-jazeera